[Music]
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift Katy Perry did
her best not to throw shade at Taylor
Swift during Sunday's American Idol but
the swish-swish singer couldn't quite
commit swish-swish-swish before one Idol
hopeful auditioned for the panel Perry's
fellow judge Luke Bryan asked him who he
looks up to as a musical artist Taylor
Swift Taylor Swift I love her song as
well the beef between the pop stars
supposedly started when Perry hired
backup dancers away from Swift's tour
years ago Swift then hired Perry's
longtime songwriter max Martin to help
her write her 2014 hit bad blood
which is reportedly about Perry during a
live streamed conversation with Arianna
Huffington in June 2017 Perry opened up
about her feud with Swift revealing that
she thought it was time the two make
amends I forgive her and I'm sorry for
anything I ever did and I hope the same
from her and I I think it's actually
like I think it's time but from the
looks of it these two may not be besties
anytime soon I love her as a songwriter
as well
[Music]